coming up next week at his Strasburg
cannery
the brexit any presidency and
counterterrorism
welcome to the agenda the UK's decision
to leave the European Union is seeing
that lose a prime minister and sparked a
leadership crisis in the opposition
Labour Party but what now for Europe
post brexit a two-day European Council
brought the outgoing Prime Minister
David Cameron face to face with EU
leaders in Brussels to discuss the
implications of the referendum result
the UK government is still to trigger
article 50 and despite the fact that he
will not be a part of future
negotiations
Cameron is urged for constructive talks
on Britain's withdrawal he leaders are
made it clear that going forward the UK
must accept principles of freedom wants
access to the single market Mbps will
discuss the outcome of the summit on
Tuesday morning the fallout from the
breakfast will be wind ranging when a
media example the resignation of the EU
commissioner for financial services
people till now the race is on to find
his replacement the extraordinary
plenary session convened in the wake of
the UK referendum the president of the
Parliament paid tribute to the outgoing
commissioner and MEP x' gave Lord Hill a
standing ovation but time now to move on
a meeting will take place and the
Economic and Monetary Affairs Committee
with Commissioner John roughs case
following the relocation of Commissioner
portfolios
from July the first it's annoying to the
Netherlands and ahoy to Slovakia and
state echo with the rotating council
presidency of the EU at the plenary on
Tuesday MEP zat counselling Commission
review the outgoing Dutch presidency but
their priorities included migration and
controlling borders jobs and growth and
on Wednesday the Slovak presidency will
present their priorities for the months
ahead and now for the news in brief
representatives of the Commission will
present the priorities for 2017 on
Wednesday Wednesday sees MEP fate and
the mandate for negotiation to the EU
Council on plans to improve and simplify
energy efficiency labeling on household
electrical items such as dishwashers
their fridges should get long-term
spending plans be adjusted to account
for migration and terrorism MVPs discuss
changes to the multi-annual financial
framework for 2014-2020 on Tuesday and
vote on Wednesday and finally a European
Coast Guard and border management system
is set to get green-lighted at the
plenary under the regulation there'll be
1,500 strong rapid reserve pool
deplorable within days that with the
ability to interview the Schengen area
is under threat the hope is that this
new tool could also protect against a
threat of terrorism the parliament and
council have already struck a
provisional deal final vote to confirm
that takes place on Wednesday
and that's all we have this agenda take
care and enjoy the week